His Excellency meets A
Rasmal Martinez,
President of the UN Habitat Assembly.
Excellencies,
distinguished delegates,
ladies and gentlemen,
it is my utmost pleasure to be here
and as pick up delegation from Malaysia.
We congratulate and express our deepest appreciation
by the good work of UN Habitat
under the leadership of the exactly director
that is 3 Mai Moana Muhammad Sharif.
Excellencies,
Malaysia recognizes the urgency
and importance of addressing global crisis.
Covid 19 has disrupted the global economy,
effective livelihoods and widen inequality.
Climate change crisis
has also caused floods and natural disasters
impacting our people's well being
and put our planetary health at risk.
In view of the above,
the cause for coherence
and comprehensive trouble cooperation,
it is now most urgent to take both step to pursue
the last seven years
achieving the Sustainable Development Goals before 2030.
Excellences,
Malaysia commits to the 2030 Agenda.
Under the leadership of our Prime Ministers
Anoy Ibrahim,
Malaysia has introduced Madani policy
focused upon sustainability,
innovation and good governance
with values of respect, trust,
care and compassion to attain racial harmony.